hey everyone
it has been a very long time since we
last joined one of these
online conversations actually it's
really hard for me to believe as i sit
here right now recognizing that it has
been
about you know a year in change since we
did the first of these at the start of
this
crazy period that we
have been going through and we thought
that perhaps we had reached the end of
and certainly in various parts of the
world we're recognizing
that we have not yet reached the end but
it's good to join back together
and let me start by noting that even
though we've not been doing these live
sessions for a little while it has been
because we have been
busy working
at the world science festival we have
not been sitting on our hands we have
been
developing
the
traditional world science festival
programs that many of you are familiar
with from watching
either the live events in new york or
brisbane australia or from our digital
presence on on youtube and so forth and
we've been developing a version of those
programs to
distribute
purely digitally obviously having live
events has not been something we can do
for a while hopefully we will be able to
return to live in the not too distant
future
but
we've taken the time and this is what
we've been doing to try to
not just put out digital versions of
what we have done in the past but rather
to use
this different medium
to create programs that in some ways may
be better
different perhaps is the right word to
use but in some ways they may be better
than the programs that we can do in a
live theater because look there are
things you can do in the digital world
that you can't do in the real world let
me give you an example i can show you a
little visual of what we have been doing
you know we've been
shooting some of these in a green screen
environment and look that's the kind of
stage that we have been able to create
of course in the digital world you can't
do that in the real world this is
actually a little
still image as well as that video image
from a program that we are doing that we
will release next week so we're going to
start releasing these programs next week
and that program is a program on the
age-old question of
is math discovered
or
is math invented is it really out there
or is it something that we create in the
human mind and
to really bring those ideas home most
forcefully we have a conversation you
can see the folks that i was in
discussion with just a little while ago
you got david albert shelley goldstein
some of you will also
recognize
max
tegmark sylvia jonas is there as well
philosopher of mathematics and a real
wide ranging conversation on this
question that look nobody knows the
answer to it even einstein didn't know
the answer to this one he certainly had
his opinion on the role of mathematics
in trying to describe the physical world
but these are the kinds of programs and
the delivery format that
we will start to release next week and i
think we're going to probably release
these programs i don't know i don't want
to commit to any particular
frequency but on the order of every
other week so we'll begin with that
program on his math reality
will then
probably turn to a program that we just
shot a couple
weeks ago on cosmology
a real interesting conversation that i
had with andre linde allen guth we'll
also have a program that may actually be
released first on language
right
where does language come from and is the
human brain wired for language or is it
something that we simply learn from
spending time in the midst of others who
speak a given
language and you know we had the people
you'd expect in a program of that sort
noam chomsky
the great
linguist of
the 20th and even 21st century stephen
pinker is in that conversation
daniel dorr evelina federenco
folks who study
the neural processes that underlie
language as well as the role of language
in allowing groups of individuals to
function more effectively than they
could otherwise that's what language has
meant to do we've seen of course
language can be twisted and used for
other purposes i'm not going to get into
a big political thing here but you all
know that i am perhaps among i like to
think of myself as among the most
open-minded of physicists yeah i'm a
hard-nosed physicalist materialist but i
am willing to entertain ideas that are
not consonant with our understanding of
the physical world
myth religion story things of that sort
but seeing them through the lens of the
role that they play
in
our attempt to make sense of this
opaque weird wonderful
confounding reality in which we find
ourselves right so i'm willing to
entertain those ideas but what i'm not
willing to entertain
are people who use language to mislead
to misinform especially when that kind
of misinformation as we have seen most
recently can be deadly deadly right we
could be done with this
pandemic but at least in this country i
know many of you are watching from other
places but in this country the
resistance to the insight of science
which can save lives is is stunning and
the willingness of certain political
figures to promulgate the lies that some
people take on board and use to help
them make decisions which ultimately can
determine life and death
is horrific reprehensible
and so
that kind of open-mindedness i certainly
do not have okay anyway enough with that
let's turn to the pure
wonder wondrous ideas of of of the
universe and reality let me begin i'm
going to take your questions of course
that's going to be
one of the dominant things that we do
here today but i did want to spend a
little bit of time i don't know maybe
5-10 minutes or something like that
just
focusing upon some of
the things that
have come to light since we last joined
together
one of those is the announcement of the
event horizon telescope and again i i
suspect that many of you have seen these
results but it's kind of nice to have it
all put together in one short summary
which is what i'm going to give you here
so you all remember that the event
horizon telescope it made worldwide news
back i think it was was it april of 2019
i think it was yeah i remember i was
giving a talk at the uh simon's
foundation on the very day that the
first image of a black hole was released
by the event horizon telescope you know
this consortium
of eight radio telescopes around the
globe able to
take radio data blend it in a manner
that effectively creates a telescope
that is essentially as big as
in some sense the earth itself we should
actually do
a section a discussion on
you know that approach very long
baseline interferometry how that
actually works but let's put that to the
side so so they
gave us this first image of a of a black
hole and i think we can probably show
you that image of a of a black hole now
that's old news right the new news is
that they have
focused their data gathering
power
not on m87 which is the galaxy in which
that initial black hole was imaged but
rather
on centaurus a that's a
galaxy about 13 million light years away
somewhat closer than m87 it's a very
bright
radio galaxy it's bright in the radio
wave so if your eyes could see radio
waves that would be a bright spot from
centaurus a it has a black hole in its
center about 55 million
solar masses right so the black hole in
m87 is about 6 billion solar masses much
lighter
black hole it's much heavier much more
massive in the more precise language
than the black hole the center of the
milky way galaxy which is about 4
million solar masses but what they've
been able to do is image
the
black hole in centaurus a and in
particular
give incredibly high resolution
images of the jets that stream from
that black hole so i think we may have
some of the imagery there you can sort
of see the jets that are streaming i
think we may have a close-up that they
provided to us through that data you see
it right there and so
black holes many black holes have these
brilliant jets that stream
from them
they are still somewhat mysterious i
mean these jets have been known for a
very long time there are many theories
regarding how these jets form
magnetic fields may be vital to
shooting the particles along these
particular trajectories that yield these
incredibly
long jets from black holes but still
people are somewhat
uncertain about the exact physical
processes that take place and so one of
the things that the event horizon
telescope is doing is providing the most
high resolution data images of these
jets
allowing people to push forward
on those kinds of ideas and just to give
a sense there's this
little video again many of you may have
seen it that gives a feel for the the
different scales
involved when you're talking about a
black hole and the jets and the
different
devices that allow us to
image the structure on different scales
so if you can run this little
video josh you can start say with you
know event horizon telescope down at the
radio detection of a black hole but then
on the bottom of the screen you'll see
the scale is changing
and
the device that was employed to get the
data that you're now observing so the
very long baseline array
gives you images of the same object on
different scales on longer scales so you
see that there's such an incredibly
large dynamic range of scales when
you're talking about
imaging these massive objects in the
cosmos
and it really is a testament to the
power of
astronomical progress that we can
observe the universe in so many
different ways radio waves visible x-ray
with different devices giving us
different insights different views of
the universe so again it's just exciting
collection of
advances as the event horizon telescope
and these other
telescopes push forward in giving us
these images of the cosmos another
breakthrough of a sort
that was announced not too long ago
comes from ligo remember ligo that's the
laser interferometer gravitational wave
observatory that is this device that
itself made headlines a little bit
before the event horizon telescope back
in
2015
ligo you will recall
achieved the first direct detection of
gravitational waves right remember the
basic idea was just a little
schematic animation just to
put us all in the same frame of mind if
you have two large astronomical bodies
two black holes two neutron stars
whatever that are rapidly orbiting each
other they disturb the fabric of space
and those disturbances spread outward in
a ripple like wave-like manner known as
gravitational waves and if you're
downstream from those waves
you will feel those waves because
anything in the wake gets compressed and
stretched compressed and stretched by
these disturbances in the fabric of
space-time
now as i'm fond of saying when you look
at an image of the earth stretching and
compressing to that magnitude you might
think it would be trivial to detect a
gravitational wave but of course
that image is not too scale
the actual stretching and compressing of
a body like the earth for a typical
astronomical event giving rise to a
gravitational wave the stretching and
compression would be less than an atomic
diameter
right so that's the challenge and what
ligo achieved
is building a device that could measure
those tiny
disturbances those tiny
differences in path length in their
particular case traversed by laser light
down these four kilometer long tunnels
that make up the gravitational wave
observatory okay so that's the um
the old news now the semi old news that
many people have asked me about and
maybe it's on some of your minds as well
you're like okay so they detected the
collision of two black holes that's what
we
were all excited about back in 2015.
is that it
just one event no the amazing thing is
that ligo has continued to regularly
observe gravitational waves from a
variety of sources now
many of those sources were again binary
black hole systems much like the
original one that got everybody excited
got the media coverage there have also
been detections of neutron stars
that have spiraled around each other
collided and that way set off a
gravitational wave what's happened most
recently and this is really quite cool
is that
lygon also virgo which is a
gravitational wave observatory in italy
they detected
the merger the collision between not a
black one a black hole not a neutron
star in a neutron star
but rather a black hole
and a neutron star
and that is an interesting and rarer
kind of event but
indeed they detected two instances of
that
fairly recently one involved i believe
was a nine
solar mass black hole nine times the
mass of the sun that merged with the
neutron star whose mass was
about 1.9
times the mass of the sun and then a
second instance with the six solar mass
black hole and i think it was a 1.5
solar mass neutron star anyway don't
don't
quote me on the details of that but
that's um again an exciting development
pressing on with trying to understand
these cosmological astrophysical
processes but now observing them
not with radio waves not with visible
light not ultraviolet light but rather
with a new kind of radiation well not
not new in the universe but new in our
capacity to be sensitive to that
radiation
gravitational radiation
gravitational waves so that's a a very
exciting development let me just um give
two other
fun things that have happened recently
or at least that i've become aware of
read about i don't think it's old news
but um my water is a little bit filthy
but what am i gonna do drink it anyway
hey when you're out in the country
you're gonna get bugs i tell my daughter
every time there's a bug walking by my
daughter sophia you know
gets all freaked out
sophia if you're watching i just drank a
bug okay so so there okay anyway back to
um the science of things
there's um a whole area of
of research that is enormously exciting
that goes under the rough-heading
quantum biology
which is look we are all familiar that
quantum mechanics is relevant to the
microscopic realm molecules atoms
subatomic particles and so forth
but in certain circumstances
the physics of those microscopic
entities can directly
influence the behavior of macroscopic
systems and
and birds songbirds in particular is an
interesting case in point because
there's now well there's been growing
evidence for a long
period of time
that
certain
bird migrations
are guided by quantum processes right
that's kind of weird bird migration
governed by quantum processes i mean how
how does that go well
there is a particular protein
molecule cryptochrome or cryptochrome 4
i believe is called and cryptochrome 4
is a protein molecule that is found in
the eye of songbird so you see a nice
little image of a songbird on your
screen right now
and the point is this particular
molecule
is able to sense changes in
magnetic fields
right how does it do that well the
magnetic field in which cryptochrome 4
may be immersed has the capacity
to cause a couple of electrons to become
unpaired and separated brought to
distinct parts of the molecule now those
electrons like any electron they spin
around
and as they spin around they generate a
little magnetic field of their own
that's why
particles can be sensitive to a magnetic
field and indeed the electron spins as
we call them can either be parallel or
anti-parallel and quantum physics
allows us to understand the probability
that a given pair of electrons will be
spinning parallel or anti-parallel now
the magnetic field in which that
molecule is immersed affects those
probabilities
and somehow in a way that's still
not completely understood by any means
songbirds are able to
sense the changes
in the ratio of pair parallel versus
antiparallel spins
of electrons in the cryptochrome for
protein molecules in their eyes
and because the magnetic field
affects those probabilities in essence
the songbird is sensitive to the
magnetic field now the magnetic field of
the earth is a potent example
because
the magnetic field of the earth is
something by which you can guide
yourself
gives you a directionality
so apparently these songbirds are able
to sense the changes in the quantum
probabilities
of the electron spin direction
in their eye as influenced by the
earth's magnetic field and in that way
guide their navigation i mean it's um
it's really quite
wondrous you know light comes into the
eye causes these electrons to separate
magnetic field of the earth affects the
direction of their
magnetic orientation and the bird is
somehow able to sense that we have to
have a great program on this
it's a little bit older now but it is
one of our most popular programs on
quantum biology you should check it out
on the youtube page um of world science
festival um but that is again you know i
think a real exciting
overlap between physics of the micro
world and physics of the macro world in
a very concrete case
in which a biological system is directly
responding to
quantum
processes one final
development i'll quickly mention before
getting to some of your questions
you may recall that there was this
this
astronomical anomaly perhaps people
described it
it was this oblong rock like object
whose name
i will try to pronounce but you no doubt
should correct i think it's
that right someone tell me someone
record it and then i simply can mouth it
and i'll use your correct pronunciation
but anyway you know what i'm talking
about because you saw the images of it
because it was flying around the
internet that this object
might be an alien ship an alien craft
evidence of extraterrestrial
intelligence my friend
avi loeb
at harvard was pushing this
interpretation quite strongly
wrote a book i forget the title of the
book which made the case
that this object we see the object back
up on the screen that this object
is um
strong evidence or
convincing evidence
or not too weak evidence i don't know
which description he actually gave is
probably on the stronger side
of extraterrestrial
life and part of the um
part of the reason for this
was at first
some interpreted this object perhaps
it's something more familiar like a
comet you know comets are not i mean
they're cool but they're not evidence of
we don't think they're evidence of
extraterrestrial life or intelligence
but the problem was
when people
studied the emotion of
uh should i try to pronounce it again
yeah i wish i had another name what's it
called oh or oh my moi when people try
yeah i'm
i'm doing my best here when when people
studied the trajectory
of this object
they found
when they studied the details of gases
that were coming off it that should have
been coming off if it was a comet
following a
comet-like trajectory that there wasn't
any evidence for the carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide tail
that you would anticipate
from the evaporation of those volatile
molecules from
a comet and that i think is
among
the strong pieces of evidence that
people put forward that this is not
you know this is not your grandfather's
is not your grandmother's comet right
it's got to be something else
now what has happened more recently is
some scientists have asked themselves
well what if this object
has a slightly different composition
from what we're familiar with with
ordinary comets what if rather than
carbon monoxide carbon dioxide what if
it's made instead of
nitrogen hydrogen and water now why
would that be interesting well number
one
if you make the assumption that that is
the composition you can
make everything agree with the
observation so that's great right there
but then the second question is where
would that kind of an object come from
and the answer that some have suggested
is
if you had sort of a shard
a chip
a chunk
of an exoplanet a sort of pluto-like
exoplanet
then that would be the kind of
composition that you would imagine so if
a little chunk of an exoplanet got
knocked off you know something smashed
into it whatever you can well imagine
those processes
then that
apparently according to recent studies
gives us a very good explanation for
this object without the necessity of
introducing e.t
now look i'm not against
extraterrestrial life don't get me wrong
i am highly skeptical
that
we have seen evidence of that yet
and this one particular example that was
put out into the press got a lot of
attention
and uh avi love certainly pressed this
case strongly maybe should have him on
so he can discuss
educate me um
why this truly is evidence of
extraterrestrial life i don't think it
is but i'd be more than happy if avi
could change my mind on that i don't
think he will succeed but we'll have him
on at some point have that conversation
the
analysis that was recently done
to me again
is exactly what women anticipate to
happen there's some sort of anomaly you
see up there in the sky at first you
don't know what it is it doesn't fit
into the pattern of things that you used
to sing fine you can jump to the extreme
explanation that it's extraterrestrial
intelligence or you can go back to the
drawing board try to understand the
physics and the astronomy
more fully
and then
more
easily
accepted explanations begin to bubble up
and i think this idea that a chunk or a
chip off a pluto like exoplanet i think
it's a
pretty pretty interesting pretty good
explanation but um
we'll see where that leads one other
quick thing before i turn to your
questions
i see some a number of people have asked
me about the programs that we will be
having at world science festival i had a
list of those programs it seems to have
disappeared so i'll have to go by memory
yeah so i mentioned we have a language
program coming up
math and reality program a cosmology
program we're doing a program on
the nature of self the nature of the
other
the so-called theory of mind that is
each individual on planet earth tends to
ascribe a consciousness to other
individuals that look and act like they
do
what's the evolutionary basis for that
what's the uh
evolution of utility
of that kind of idea excuse me
um we've got programs
that will
explore the
work being done to manipulate the human
brain and to connect it
with various kinds of technologies
we'll be doing programs that
investigate psychedelics
you know a particularly
interesting subject from i think anybody
who has an open mind some of you may
know i had a lot of not a lot a couple
conversations
with joe rogan and psychedelic seem to
always come up in those conversations i
think he's quite fond of talking about
that subject because it's um it's a
really wondrous subject
immortality everlasting life is that
possibly in the cards we'll have a
program that will be exploring that
particular subject and many others so
again starting next week
on the average of every other week those
programs will be released going forward
okay with that let me now turn
to some of the questions that you guys
have
and i see a bunch of them or come down
and the other thing i sort of like to do
if uh if you
could
we always like to have a record of this
anybody who's up for it can you just put
in the chat where you are connecting
from we did this on our very first of
these live sessions
a long time ago and it's always nice to
sort of see the different countries
scroll by but as that's happening let me
now turn to a couple questions um here's
a question from
maria
in spain and in fact maria if i'm
understanding correctly is
connected to world science festival we
have this program called world science
scholars
and world science scholars is
a program that gathers together some of
the
most talented
mathematical minds young mathematical
minds high school typically around the
world joins them together into a
digital community that they learn from
each other they learn from
researchers who 10 20 30 years ago were
very much like them
well adept in
the mathematical arts and have used
those talents to
influence and change the world in
various ways so i'm glad to see that
some of the scholars are
are
watching and i believe is all at 15
years old so here's maria's question how
can supermassive black holes grow so
quickly to reach such a huge mass
in the early stage of
the universe
good question maria to a first
approximation i don't know the answer we
don't really know the answer to that
there are theories about that but you're
right i mean if you're talking about you
know these enormous
black holes i mean it's
it's stupendous enough to think about a
black hole whose mass is four million
times out of the sun in the center of
our galaxy but you're talking about
black holes
six billion times the mass of the sun in
m87
and the record holders go much more than
that
many tens
of times the billion 10 10 billion times
the mass of the sun 50 billion 60
billion i think there's an anticipation
that the 100 billion solar mass
mark will be cracked
how does that happen well it could be
that
black holes in the early universe
may form more directly right we usually
have in mind that
matter comes together through the force
of gravity into stars stars burn for a
while use up their nuclear fuel wood and
there isn't anything left to hold them
up the star collapses in on itself
yielding a black hole but that
typically would be stellar mass black
holes but in the early universe people
have wondered about the possibility that
large clouds of gas and dust might
collapse directly to very large black
holes which themselves
could then
collide and merge with other large black
holes and in that way kind of jump start
the process and to use another metaphor
of a similar sort to
leapfrog to the large mass scale without
having to go sequentially from the solar
mass scale upwards so that's one
possibility but the bottom line is
it's still an open question so
maybe maria a few years maybe you will
tell us the answer
suraj from nepal oh another world
science scholar that's nice thank you
world science scholars for uh
hanging out with us a little bit today
siraj asks in many situations the
entropic two step explains how a system
goes from low entropy to high entropy
but i'm confused in case that all the
laws of physics hold even if time
elapses backward for instance you had
shown that the broken pieces of glass
can even form from the complete unbroken
glass if reverse the velocity vector of
all broken pieces and so on absolutely
right so how can we explain this in
terms of entropy so yeah it's a it's a
very good question
siraj
the language that you use the entropic
two step
i should emphasize is not standard
language that does come from my latest
book
and it's a phrase that i like to use but
in tropic two-step for those of you who
have not read my book you've not read my
book come on guy no for those of you who
have not read my book the idea is that
there is a general tendency
of entropy to always be on the rise to
increase right for disorder to increase
over time
but
it's a tendency
and moreover
that tendency does not dictate what
happens on
subscales of the entire universe it's
the overall entropy of the kitkat and
caboodle the whole thing that increases
over time that doesn't prevent entropy
in some regions from going down so long
as in the process
enough entropy is released to the wider
world so that the entropy can go down
here so long as it goes up
in aggregate and that's the two step
down here up there
and so that is a vital process as suraj
points out in the formation of structure
in the universe how do stars form you've
got this cloud of gas it collapses down
into an orderly object called a star but
in the process enough heat and light is
released carrying away entropy to the
wider world
so order forms here disorder is expelled
and
when you tally up the numerical values
the disorder wins so the disorder in
aggregate goes up but then suraj says
okay cool i got that
but
how do you how do you square that with
the
possibility allowed by the laws of
physics
that any process that we see taking
place in the usual temporal orientation
like dropping a glass and it shatters
the laws of physics absolutely say that
the glass in principle can unshatter
it can unshadow that does not violate
laws of physics
now if it were to unshatter all the
pieces jump up and come back together
how would you square that with the
second law of thermodynamics and the
answer is
the second law of thermodynamics is not
a law in a conventional sense
you know we talk about you know
newton's second law f equals m a our
expectation is that that law would
always be true i mean it gets replaced
by quantum mechanics but let's just
think classically for a moment f equals
m a is meant to always be true an iron
clad rock solid etched in stone law
cannot be violated the second law of
thermodynamics with entropy on the rise
is not like that
the second law
articulates an overwhelming tendency
of entropy to increase but it does not
rule out
the rare possibility that entropy can
decrease
and so if a glass were to spontaneously
come back together
we would not scratch our heads and
wonder what happened to the second law
we would say oh
that's one of those incredibly rare
processes in which entropy went down
now
it's such a rare process
that
we
[Music]
would be
thoroughly shocked if it were to happen
and we would look for other explanations
behind the scenes
but in the end of the day if there were
no other explanation it would not
violate the second law of thermodynamics
for that process to take place
okay let's see what else uh
we have got here um
um
yasir masood asks do you think at least
part of the motivation for a multiverse
is to solve the fine-tuning problem
thereby
negating the need for god
yeah
i do i mean i don't know that all
physicists who subscribe to this way of
thinking about things
would frame it exactly as you have
yasser
but
the beauty
let's just talk positively the beauty
of the idea of a multiverse it's got
some
qualities that i would not consider
beautiful but there is one that is
beautiful which is this which is there
are certain questions that we consider
to be fundamental if we're dealing with
a single universe
and among those questions are the ones
that you're referring to is how did it
come to be
that the mass of the electron the
strength of the electromagnetic force
the strength of the gravitational force
and all of the known qualities of the
physical world that we have measured
how did they come to acquire
the particular values
that allow
for atoms and molecules to form and
stars to form and planets that form and
on at least one of the planets called
planet earth life to form because we
have also learned that if you change
those numbers
some of those numbers by even a few
percent
then the physical processes change
in a manner that prevents
the formation
of molecules and atoms
stars planets and people and so
in a universe a single universe that's a
puzzle
and some would say well god
as you are indicating yes here god set
those numbers
god was back and said let me see what
should i do yeah let me make the mass of
the electron let me change gravity
because god wanted
adam or whichever
theological approach you like to focus
your attention on god wanted the world
to exist god set those values to allow
the world to exist now most of us
scientists don't find that it could be
true
but don't find that a very satisfying
answer we want an answer that comes from
physical principles that we can
understand and calculate with and in a
single universe it's very hard to answer
that question nobody has in a scientific
manner but in a multiverse and this is
why i called it beautiful
in a multiverse you can imagine and the
math supports this
that there's so many universes out there
with so many different values for all of
those quantities
that you can argue forcefully
that you expect at least one and
probably much more than one of those
universes to have the values for those
quantities that we observe here
you know the analogy that i like to use
you know if you go to a clothing store
and you uh there's one suit on the rack
and you put it on it's a perfect fit
you're like whoa that's weird
they just happen to have my size wow
what luck
but if you go to a clothing store that
has every size suit on the rack and the
sales person goes up and picks your size
off of the rack and hands it to you and
it fits perfectly that's not a mystery
any longer no fine tuning no luck
every possibility for suit size was out
there
and of course yours was among those
possibilities similarly if every
possibility for the values of those
numbers those qualities of the universe
are out there in some universe
no mystery why one of those universes or
maybe many of those universes
have the qualities that we are familiar
with so
does you do view that as negating god i
don't know
maybe you say
god's even
more grand
god didn't just create one universe god
created the multiverse i mean if you
if you want to go in that direction
and
i'm not encouraging you or discouraging
you from that direction
the multiverse doesn't prevent you from
doing so
tanzu asks professor green is it true
that physicists are losing their hope in
string theory
i have to take a drink of water for this
one tanzu
no the answer is no
now
i understand where you're coming from
because there are those out there in the
world
who
for reasons that
i think are best analyzed through
psychotherapy
not through physics there are those out
there who feel the need
to chip away at string theory or
to constantly
focus upon
qualities that we know well and are all
too happy to share with the public that
we don't fully understand that haven't
yet reached the level of mature
development
that we anticipate
one day achieving that's the nature of
scientific research you don't have the
answer
even after decades of hard work you may
not have
the answer so look
perhaps one way of addressing your
question tends to there are some who
would say that any theory that involves
a multiverse and string theory in some
ways has certainly invoked
a multiverse doesn't have to but it
certainly has that as a possibility some
would say once you're in multiverse land
you're no longer doing physics no longer
doing science and they say that because
if you're talking about realms that you
can't visit
you can't experiment with you can't you
know focus a telescope on then what are
you doing you're not doing science
and while i understand that perspective
and in some ways there are aspects of
that perspective that i subscribe to as
well
my own view and the view of many of my
colleagues is
if
you're developing a mathematical theory
it's not the case
that every quality of that mathematical
theory needs itself to be observable you
just need enough qualities of the
mathematical theory to be observable
hopefully you observe them confirming
the theory based upon those observations
and then you're willing to entertain
those implications of the math
that may not be observable such as the
possibility of other universes
so
it's a very limited
way of thinking
and
you know look some of my closest friends
have that perspective
and that's fine
but it's not a perspective that i hold
not a perspective that many of my
colleagues hold and moreover let me just
finish this little answer by saying
it's not impossible to
get evidence for a multiverse
if there are other universes out there
it's conceivable
that we could
interact with them have some sort of
collision with another universe think of
many bubbles in a bubble bath this is a
cosmic bubble bath of course but bubble
universes can hit each other
and the calculations suggest that if we
were to have that kind of an encounter
with another universe
there would be evidence for that in the
so-called microwave background radiation
left over from the big bang in our
universe tiny temperature differences
across the night sky
might give us indirect evidence that we
were hit by another universe indirect
evidence that is that there is another
universe indirect evidence that is
for the multiverse
so
we're not there yet
string theory's not there yet but no the
general state of the field is one of
excitement not one in which as tanzu
asks that people are losing hope
barna balint asks
hey brian my question is
what steps if any do you take during
your life to stay in a cosmic
perspective to what point do you think
is it beneficial to stay in that state
and uh barna
is asking that
question from
hungary
yeah i think it's a real important
question you know it's a it's a deep
life question i think it's a question
that each of us needs to answer in our
own highly personal highly subjective
way
but i do try to keep
a perspective
which
sees
the human species
within a grand cosmological unfolding
which partly involves
the evolutionary processes by which the
earth formed the sun formed complex
molecules formed complex molecules came
together
into robust collections that
were then fortunate to
have the currents of life surge through
them and certain sub-collections of
those ingredients gain conscious
awareness and certain
sub-sub-collections of those
can call themselves human beings and so
when you see
yourself
as a biological machine
fashioned by the laws of physics and the
laws of evolution by natural selection
and when you recognize that your
behaviors and the behaviors of others in
the species
are
molded by our physical makeup and are
influenced deeply
by the long lineage of evolutionary
unfolding
it allows you to see the world
in a different light
it isn't that
you give up
seeing the world in the more day-to-day
way of course i live like everybody else
in the day-to-day moment-to-moment and i
get frustrated and upset and angry about
things like everybody else does just ask
my wife who perhaps is listening to this
in the house across the way but at the
same time i feel like i'm able to
take in the world
through parallel
levels of narrative
where the everyday is only one of those
and these parallel levels take into
account
these larger stories the evolutionary
story the cosmological story the cosmic
story
and by
allowing this kind of bifurcation this
kind of ramification if you will of a
single experience of the everyday and
allowing it to open up
into these other ways of seeing that
same experience viewing it as if you
were
some
alien watching planet earth from some
distant cosmological vantage point or
viewing it as if you were a molecule
buffeted to and fro by the laws of
physics
being able to see the world
in these different levels of analysis i
find enriches life
and i think also gives you
i don't know
more compassion
for the things in the world that
you find difficult
it doesn't mean that you have to be
complacent but i think it gives you more
compassion
for
qualities of the world that would
otherwise
be
much more difficult to live with
so i don't know if that uh
fully answers your question but
um if you're interested more again i
don't like to turn these into
advertisements but until the end of time
my latest book is all about
these ideas so you might again
i'm not asking you to buy it get in a
library
bootleg copy i'm sure you can find it
online but you might find it interesting
to go through as i as i lead the reader
through
the entropic story and the biological
story the chemical story
the narrative story the philosophical
story the psychological story
and on to
the grandest of all stories which is the
one that takes us from the beginning of
time to the very end and that's why the
book is called until the end of time
okay
um
from there let's see what else we have
um
wise man
asks hello sir i am from india i want to
be an astrophysicist so i want to do an
ms in astrophysics and astronomy which
undergraduate engineering degree is best
to do um
you know again i wish i could give a
blanket answer to questions of that sort
which do come up now and again
the bottom line is
you have to figure out what you really
want to do to just be an astrophysicist
may sound like you've made the decision
but
what aspect of astrophysics is it the
observational side
is it the theoretical side is it
understanding the
computational side so that you can
create these very detailed simulations
of astrophysical phenomenon and
understand them more fully there's so
many flavors of astrophysicist
that it's hard to answer without
knowing which you really
have in mind
and
i but i guess what i'd suggest though is
engineering is great
but alongside your engineering degree if
you really want to do
any of those arenas of astrophysics
you've got to get some pure physics in
there too you got to know the basics of
electricity magnetism the basics of
general relativity hopefully
the basics of thermodynamics now you may
do that in engineering degree but if you
don't
ensure that you cover those subjects as
they
are absolutely vital to being able to go
forward and do research in these arenas
um purpose believe asks brian can
science be explained and understood
without any
mathematical models
i mean give two quick answers to that
i think you can
grasp the essential ideas of physics
without
mathematics playing a role right i mean
this may not be what you're asking
purpose believe but
i mean the whole point of of my books
and many others who write books is to
try to communicate the key ideas of
physics without the math right so yeah
you can you can understand
these ideas without the math but if you
really want to deeply understand
not just the
overarching principles but the
nitty-gritty details
that's where you really need mathematics
and it's fairly indispensable as we have
seen over the course of many centuries
now
getting back to
a program that we will release next week
this program on math and reality that i
made reference to before
one of the things that came up in that
program as you will see
is this interesting program to
reformulate
mathematics without the
traditional techniques without the
traditional symbols without the
traditional approaches that you and i
would call
mathematics it's sort of mathematics
without numbers
and it's an interesting program that has
been applied to certain areas of physics
classical mechanics in particular so
there is a version of classical
mechanics i've never really studied this
um this is quite second hand that i'm
describing here there's a version of
classical mechanics that would be
unrecognizable if you were going in
looking for
the usual formulas and symbols that we
call mathematics so
that's a more sophisticated version of
an answer to your question
whether you can push that program to
cover all of physics i think is
something that is still unknown that's
um
not something that has yet been settled
okay what else have we got um
jim gobetz hey brian glad you're back
good to be back jim
if gravity jim asks is quantized and the
force carrier is a graviton how can it
emanate from a black hole or merger if
nothing can escape am i reading this
incorrectly that's a very good question
and um
the way to think about it
is
let's take a gravitational wave for
instance
the wave let's say two black holes
colliding merging forth the
gravitational wave isn't really
emerging from inside
the black hole rather
the black holes themselves are
disturbing
their environment
and that
disturbance of the environment
which can be described classically in
terms of this wave-like motion or
quantum mechanically in terms of
gravitons
shooting outward it's all happening in
the external region outside the event
horizon of
the black hole so
in that sense you really shouldn't think
of the gravity as sort of coming out
of the black hole the gravity the shape
of space-time is the response of the
environment to the presence of the black
hole to the motion of the black holes to
the collision of the black holes so it's
an environmental effect as opposed to
something internal that then is thrust
outward to the wider environment
as another world science scholar
question
from
duru in turkey
and let's see what we have here um
i know that inside of black holes are
very cold
and they absorb every form of energy
absorption of energy should raise its
temperature but still it's extremely
cold can you give details about the
temperature thing about black holes
yeah so
one of the
most stupendous discoveries of the 1970s
emerged from the work of jacob
beckenstein israeli physicist and
stephen hawking
stephen hawking is stephen hawking
and
what their combined work revealed
is that black holes are deeply connected
to the laws of thermodynamics thermo
heat right
and that that was deeply surprising
because at that point
black holes were these mathematical
solutions to einstein's equations of
gravity the general theory of relativity
there wasn't a connection
to temperature and and heat and entropy
all these ideas that
was at all obvious but beckenstein and
hawking showed that there is there was
and is a deep connection
and among the connections that they
revealed is that black holes do have a
temperature
and that temperature
it turns out is inversely proportional
to the mass inversely proportional to
the mass
so it's this curious situation that if
you have a very big
black hole
then the mass is very very small
and if you have a very small black hole
the temperature can be very big did i
say that right i think i did rewind the
tape anyway inverse proportionality
between temperature and mass small mass
big temperature big mass small
temperature
and to think about this
microscopically to really understand the
micro physical processes which are the
analog of you know if you have a box of
gas
you got the particles moving around and
they move quickly it's got high
temperature they move slowly it's got
low temperature you know entropy is a
count of the number of rearrangements of
those particles and so on and so forth
to understand those details
at that level that micro physical level
as applied to temperature and entropy of
a black hole has been a puzzle
for a long time
and i would say that string theory
getting back to the earlier question
is an arena that has given us our
deepest insights into that question
andrew schramager and kumaran vaffa
two
good friends of mine physicists at
harvard they were able to
understand black holes in the language
of string theory to the degree that they
could count
the rearrangement of the ingredients of
a black hole like you count the
arrangements of molecules of gas in a
box
and the count gave rise to the entropic
formula that stephen hawking and jacob
beckenstein had written down 25 years
earlier
so is that a full answer no but it's a
partial answer that we now at least can
get a sense of how to talk about entropy
of a black hole in micro physical
language so it's an ongoing story not
yet complete
but the overarching idea that
temperature is inversely proportional to
mass that is solid and well understood
okay what else have we got here
um
i think may have to actually put on my
glasses here because
there he goes all right so
hey then
asks what is super symmetry
and um what is supersymmetry
supersymmetry is uh
is a well obviously it's it's a kind of
symmetry
and it's a symmetry
of a very different sort from the ones
that you may be familiar with just from
you know everyday life the laws of
physics don't seem to care about
orientation right if i have a physical
system i understand it using the laws of
physics if i rotate that physical system
by 22 degrees it's not like i need new
laws
to understand it the laws are
rotationally invariant rotationally
symmetric
the laws that we use today
are the same laws that we use yesterday
they worked yesterday they work today
the laws in that sense are
time invariant time translation
invariant if i use the laws in you know
in in abu dhabi and they work there
i can use the exact same laws in
vancouver
right calcutta
doesn't matter the laws are invariant
under translations in space
so those are symmetries the symmetry is
an invariance of a system under some
kind of transformation
supersymmetry is a
an invariance under a transformation
that
changes
the spin of a particle
so electrons quarks protons spin a half
particles electrons and corps are the
fundamental versions
there are other particles in the world
we know of the higgs boson has been zero
and the supposition in this idea of
supersymmetry is that there may be a
complete balance
for every spin a half particle there may
be a spin zero particle and vice versa
and that would therefore suggest if this
super symmetry is realized in nature
that there are a whole slew of particles
kind of like the higgs boson but of
different
detail qualities
that have not yet been found and that
was one of the motivations for building
the super conducting supercollider down
in
in texas which got cancelled
upgraded not upgraded but
the torch was passed to the large hadron
collider in geneva was actually a
smaller machine compared to the one that
would have been built
and
the large hadron collider has searched
for these supersymmetric particles and
has yet to find them
does that mean that supersymmetry does
not exist
not necessarily maybe the particles are
are heavier maybe you needed the
superconducting super collider
to have found them and there are plans
underway china may build the next
generation accelerator
so this quality of the world that comes
out of the math
even without string theory it comes out
of the math but with string theory it
comes out of math quite forcefully
this quality of the world may or may not
be realized may or may not be true but
it's a beautiful mathematical theory
that creates a
nice
satisfying balance
between the kinds of particles that make
up reality so
many of us have written many papers on
supersymmetry heya
we we'd be thrilled if it's true but in
the end of the day the world doesn't
need to
be governed by things that we want to be
true rather
things that are true
just primal soup asks oh where'd that
question go and then it scrolled away
too quickly no scroll back here it is
personal question what prompted you to
become a vegan susan in ohio
i did say all questions are on the table
so absolutely uh susan very simple um
i was a professor at cornell in the
early 1990s i went to
an animal sanctuary in watkins glen new
york
where they had rescued all of these farm
animals that had been so
overused cows that were over milked i
mean they've been turned into like milk
production factories and they were so
damaged through that abuse that i just
felt like i can't participate
in this any longer and within about a
day or two i just
got a kind of revulsion
to
any
food of animal origin
and so i haven't eaten anything of
animal origin you know including honey
some people might question that choice
but i haven't eaten anything of animal
origin since then that was about
1995.
so going on i don't know i can't really
subtract 25 years or so
so yes that's uh that's where that came
from um
um
let's see what else uh
um
ariane garg asks is teleportation of
matter
theoretically possible it's not just
theoretically possible it
it is possible
it's undertaken
so
you know one of the beautiful things
about quantum mechanics is this quality
of the world called quantum entanglement
and quantum entanglement is this idea
that distant particles
however far apart they may be can act as
though
they are connected as if they are one
where you do something to one particle
and affects the other particle
instantaneously regardless of the
distance between them kind of crazy idea
now
that's its whole other subject that we
could spend some time talking about but
i'm just going to note that
using quantum entanglement the beautiful
thing is
you can
take two particles
and bring in a third particle that
impresses its properties on one member
of the entangled pair that then through
the entanglement is transmitted
to the distant particle
and that's a kind of teleportation you
bring a particle over here
you let it intermingle with one member
of an entangled pair through that
intermingling the qualities of the
subject particle are transmitted to the
distant particle the other member of the
entangled pair which then can acquire
the properties of the particle you
wanted to teleport and this is not
theoretical this is real
anton zeilinger many others too
have been using this technique to
teleport individual particles over great
distances
i believe that
i'm not completely sure i
have a memory that there is a a chinese
satellite that teleported particles from
the satellite to earth again i'm not 100
sure about that but i remember reading
about that quite exciting
but the bottom line is teleportation of
individual particles is undertaken
routinely it's not it's not some crazy
thing but i think the other
related question is well okay if you can
do it for individual particles can you
do star trek right can you have a
transporter you know you step in you
tell scotty energize i'm showing my age
i'm sure there's a different name of the
person that runs a transporter on the
more recent star trek franchises but
whatever scotty energize
and you get transported down to the
planet is that possible that's certainly
not possible will it ever be possible i
don't know i'm always reluctant to say
never but there's a world of difference
between teleporting a single electron a
single photon a single particle and
teleporting a big collection of
particles
whose configuration
you might be fond of
and you don't want to be disrupted in
the teleportation process itself you
know your head winds up having your hand
growing out of your forehead or
something um so i don't i don't know i
don't know if that will ever be possible
i can certainly tell you this
if they make the first teleporter of say
human beings in my lifetime
i will not be the first person to go in
yeah not me
all right i think that should give you
some some insight in that um
all right let's see what else we got
here um
um
uh what are the possible ways anas asks
what are the possible ways that our
universe came to exist well this will
this will be in our cosmology program
that's coming up
i'd say the two main contenders
although some of my colleagues might
even
object to my saying that there's any
contention among the contenders they
like to
focus upon one
as the dominant theory it's called
inflationary cosmology i'm sure you've
heard of it
it's this idea that in the early
universe there may have been
a certain kind of substance it's called
a quantum field
but very particular quantum field called
the infiton field
which has the capacity that when the
value of that field is uniform in a
little nugget of space
and has the right value
it can give rise to a repulsive version
of gravity repulsive gravity gravity
that
pushes outwards
and so if you had this little nugget
filled with inflaton field
it would push outwards and in that way
force space to expand
and ultimately the energy in that field
would transmute
into particles that would make up stars
and planets
people and so forth now the inflationary
theory has been around for 30 years
and it has been the dominant paradigm
there are issues in the inflationary
theory no doubt
among those issues taking us back to an
earlier question the inflationary theory
itself strongly suggests that we live in
a multiverse that this outward thrust of
this implaton field may not have been a
one-time unique event
but rather there may have been
many places in a wider cosmological
canvas in which these outward swellings
happen a kind of big bang after big bang
after big bang giving rise to universe
after universe after universe
now the problem with that or the
challenge with that or the opportunity
with that or the beauty of that
depending on your perspective is
how do you
test the theory like that
because if those other universes have
different properties than ours
then you say well look any observation
that we make
that we
might use to bolster our confidence
in this theory
any observation could be accommodated by
some universe in the multiverse how
would you ever rule this theory out
whatever observation you make
it's not testing the theory it's simply
delineating which universe you live in
observe the temperature of the microwave
background to be a certain value oh i'm
in that universe
which then you'd call this universe you
know and so and so that
disturbs some people
some people say that there are ways of
resolving this with so-called measures
on the multiverse that talk about the
most probable universes
and hopefully our universe is among the
most probable which would give you some
insight into why we are here
but others including some of those who
originated the inflationary theory like
paul steinhardt at princeton and we'll
have a conversation with him at some
point coming up too
so deeply unsatisfied with the
inflationary multiverse even though he
was among those who
discovered it
that he's developed a new approach
a kind of cyclic version of cosmology in
which there's one universe but it
expands and contracts and it expands and
contracts in a very specific way that
allows it to be compatible with the
second law of thermodynamics
and in that way
gives alternate explanations for things
that we have observed
and at least according to paul and his
colleagues
he believes that this theory does as
good a job
even better than the inflationary theory
and
does an end run around
what he considers the downfall of the
inflationary theory which is the
multiverse so look there are different
perspectives on this
we will kick around those in upcoming
programs the cosmology program call it
cosmology part one with alan guth andre
lindy that will focus on the
inflationary story we will have a
counterpart cosmology program that we
will release
some time in the next few months
which will be perhaps the other
perspective the paul steinhardt and
colleagues perspective and
watch them both and
come to your own conclusion about where
we stand when it comes to cosmological
theorizing
um here's a question from
[Music]
age
from ranjita is reality an illusion i
would say reality is an illusion no i
mean i think this stuff is real
right i mean i think i'm real
however
my perception
of that
reality
is not itself
a direct reflection of the reality when
i look out in the world i look behind me
i see green right i see green grass
green trees right that's real right
that's not like some
some artificial background it's real now
what's going on there is
those green leaves are reflecting
sunlight predominantly in a particular
wavelength and frequency
that light is coming into my eye
it is exciting particular molecules in
my eye causing a cascade of electrons to
flow through
certain channels which deep inside my
brain
my brain has learned to interpret as the
color green
but green in that sense no e on the end
green in that sense is happening deep
inside of my head
green is not happening out there in the
world what's happening out there in the
world is electromagnetic radiation with
electric fields oscillating at right
angles to magnetic fields in this
incredible
bath of radiation that is
suffusing my environment
my brain has simplified
that reality into something that allows
me a better chance of survival
and so that's the sense in which yeah
the tree is real
but my perception of it is not itself a
direct
mirror reflection of that reality it's a
human
interpretation of the reality
with the interpretation being determined
by a brain which itself exists because
it won a whole sequence of battles
evolution by natural selection and those
brains that interpreted the world the
way that our brains do are the brains
that prevailed
that doesn't mean that they're a direct
reflection of a reality
it means that they were good at
surviving and those are two different
things so i do draw a distinction
between
reality which is real
and our perception of that reality even
our mathematical description of that
reality which i consider to be
a deeply human response to reality as
opposed to reality itself
so i hope that gives you some
some sense on that um
craig bellaire asks hi brian
craig belair
hi brian i said that like highmark in in
the disaster riders
i did not hi mark hi brian craig blair
halifax nova scotia if you're the
richest person in the world how would
you spend your money space travel
what problem would you try to solve and
how
you know it's a
basic you're saying if i were if i were
jeff bezos
what would i do let's be concrete right
isn't he the is he the richest guy in
the world how would you spend your money
um it's such a hard question i don't
know um
you can't help but think that
mag being magnanimous and and really
trying to use the resources to
to
improve
the lot of the world right how can
anything you know be more important than
that but i will say this because
obviously the intent of the question is
you know
is jeff go into space i speak like he's
a friend of mine i've met him but he's
not a friend of mine you know is is is
the founder of amazon going to space
that you know as people said you know a
billionaire's
play toy
waste of money that could be better used
and and i guess my feeling is this let
me take it away from jeff bezos and just
speak more generally
because you can say the same thing to me
i'm not the richest man in the world but
you could say how can i support spending
billions of dollars on esoteric
experiments like the large hadron
collider
or esoteric experiments like ligo
billions of dollars to detect
gravitational waves
shouldn't we have used those billions of
dollars to better the lot of people on
planet earth so so that's a question
that you could ask me directly
and my feeling is this
i don't consider it a zero-sum game
i
recognize the deep importance of
resources being placed in a manner that
helps humanity
at the same time
we need to press forward in our
scientific understanding of the world
because
that's
what allows us number one
to invent the very things that transform
life on planet earth it's all science
it's all technology it's all insight
that comes from individuals who are
compelled to understand the world more
deeply the fact that we can talk to each
other as we are doing right now the fact
that we have life-saving technologies
around the world that rest upon
integrated circuits it all comes from
quantum mechanics
should we not have pursued quantum
mechanics because of the expense and
diverted those resources in a more
pragmatic way 80 years ago and
henceforth to the current era i would
say no
because we've learned that science
technology it's the engine of society
it's the engine of progress if used in
the right way
second point though is this
we are a deeply curious species
and and and and part of
the lifeblood of being a human being is
to allow that curiosity to
to grow to develop to expand
and so
you need to do both
allow research to press onward and have
resources to help those in need
i would say
make the zero sum game not between
helping those who are in need and
scientific research
make it between helping those who are in
need and building new bombs
you know building new fighter aircraft
you know that to me when you think about
the amount of money that america has
spent in
in in in in tragic
entanglements around the world
that to me is is the is a deeply sad
part so taking you know billionaire
space
tourists
out of the question
my version of it is a similar one and
and that's where i come down on it
all right a few more questions here
let's see what we got um i saw a good
one it just always
scrolls by too fast something about
there it is
um
yes sir raghav and as if quantum
fluctuation sparked the big bang how did
those fluctuations form without space
and time before the big bang and you're
absolutely right
i i would not be able to answer that
question without invoking a conception
of space and time and certainly when we
talk about quantum fluctuations
in the conventional way that we
calculate them if you took a course with
me
on you know quantum mechanics and
cosmology we would actually
do the calculations of the quantum
fluctuations in the early universe and
how they evolve over time
how they spread out and manifest as
temperature variations in the microwave
radiation microwave background radiation
that's that we would do the calculation
space and time would be there from the
get-go in that calculation
so you're absolutely right we make an
assumption we make an assumption that
at some point in the early universe the
concepts of space and time make sense
and that we use that arena
to be the substrate in which quantum
mechanics and the other
framework of physics that we make use of
general theory of relativity that these
are operative in that environment and
you could say they meet but where did
space and time come from and i said you
i don't know
there are ideas guesses
maybe
space and time emerge from a more
fundamental starting point of
basic ingredients that themselves may be
the molecules of space or the atoms of
space and time i don't know people are
developing ideas of this sort
but you're right when we do the
calculation of quantum fluctuations in
the early universe we absolutely make an
assumption
that there is a space
there is a time there is a space-time
environment within which quantum
mechanics operates and then we go
forward from there so you're absolutely
right no
no argument for me that's incomplete
until we can answer a question like
the origin of space and time
we're working on it not yet uh
not yet done okay um
let's see what we got um
oh scrolls by too fast um
and mal
me rotra
where'd it go
somebody's got to teach me how to stop
the scroll from scrolling but um i i'm
going to paraphrase your question the
the person whose name i just said and i
don't remember it uh how do you
distinguish between
math and fantasy how do you know when
math trends
makes the move from an abstract
discipline to describing the physical
world
and that's the art of physics
there's no algorithm
there's no
approach that we can simply give i mean
i think the fact that albert einstein
himself
got it wrong
on a number of occasions right his
general theory of relativity
was making use of what at the time was
esoteric mathematics
he was making use of riemann's ideas and
and and gauss's ideas on curved spaces
so-called differential geometry and the
language that we use today
physicists weren't using differential
geometry in einstein's era you know
einstein had to get his friend marcel
grossman
who himself was a
a math professor and grossman taught
einstein a lot of the math of
differential geometry so that einstein
could then apply it
to the fabric of space-time so there you
have this this genius this maverick
thinker using abstract math
bringing it in as a description of the
physical world but then
einstein
when his own math
gave rise to the possibility of black
holes
he said no no no no that that's
that's that's a fantasy
that's using math in a way that doesn't
reflect reality and then when his math
suggested the possibility of a big bang
and expanding cosmo he says no no no no
no no that
math is a fantasy that's using the
equations in the wrong way and in each
of those instances the maverick thinker
albert einstein was wrong black holes
look we started out today i showed you
an image of a black hole
the big bang expanding universe
beyond
question that this is
a correct description of reality
so
if einstein couldn't get it right to
know when the math was real and when the
math was a fantasy clearly there's no
algorithm there's no there's no approach
so what you do is
you suppose that the math is real you
try to extract some predictions from it
you go out and try to confirm those
predictions if you confirm those
predictions you're confident in your
assumption that the math describes the
real world grows
and you find other predictions you go
out and try to find those if you don't
find them it rules out that theory if
you do find them
increases your confidence further still
that the math is actually describing
reality so that really is the
the algorithmic approach that we can
give but it's not something that allows
you to simply look at a piece of
mathematics and
let it flow through an algorithm to
determine whether or not it's real
um
um
since
heinz holtzman asked since dark matter
is so abundant and considering that much
rarer baryonic matter is made up of more
than
dozens of particles isn't it a bit
simple to suggest only one dark matter
probably yeah
you're right
you know when you look at the uh the
ordinary matter in the world around us
you see dozens of species of particles
heinz your right electrons up quarks
down quartz strange quarks top quarks
bottom quarks
w's boson z boson you know photon gluon
i mean it's like this long list of
particles and those are the observable
particles the ones that you know we are
directly aware of we've captured them we
can see them and so forth
why think that the dark matter which is
more abundant in terms of its overall
mass fraction of the universe
perhaps five times more abundant than
the known particles why should it just
be one particle maybe it's a whole slew
of particles and the only reason people
start with one particle is because it's
simple
and wouldn't it be wonderful if a simple
answer is the right answer and moreover
going back to the question on
supersymmetry
supersymmetry it turns out
as we discussed predicts the existence
of other particles
in many versions of supersymmetry only
one of those other particles is
absolutely stable that it won't fall
apart over time into other particles
so people wondered if supersymmetry is
correct maybe that single species of
stable
exotic particle that the symmetry
predicts maybe that could be the dark
matter and here's the wonderful thing
you can then do a calculation
how much mass should that lightest
supersymmetric particle
contribute to the mass of the universe
and with almost no assumptions very few
assumptions
the mass turns out to be
just right for it to be the dark matter
and you look at that you're like oh my
god of course it's the dark matter we
just did a calculation from first
principles and the amount of mass that
this lightest of all supersymmetric
particles contributes should be equal to
the dark matter amount that we get to by
looking at the motions of stars that are
rotating around their galaxy not being
flung outward
so that gave people a lot of hope in the
80s starting in the 80s that the dark
matter was a species was a single
species of supersymmetric particles
is that right well supersymmetry has not
penned out yet our searches for
the super symmetric particles as dark
matter has not panned out
and so as the simple ideas fall by the
wayside people are willing to entertain
more complicated scenarios and among
them is a possibility as heinz suggests
that maybe there's not one particle
maybe it's many particles yes
people have certainly spent a lot of
time with that particular idea
all right a couple more questions before
we wrap up it's funny i it's like
training for a marathon i used to be
able to sit here for three hours on end
i have more difficulty uh
keeping my voice that much longer
jack burton asks professor green who is
your favorite philosopher
favorite philosopher well i got a few
uh bertrand russell
certainly among them
spectacular writer so clear
so insightful on such a wide range of
subjects that it's just really
really a remarkable
mind if you haven't read bertrand
russell you should
but the other philosopher who i have
really deep affection for in a scholarly
sense is
robert nozick
when i was a freshman at harvard back in
the 1980s i
took philosophy three
introduction to the
problems of philosophy taught by robert
nozick and
it was a an amazing experience
to be a student in the class but b
i was one of those students who would
like go and
talk to the professors i was like the
only student who would go to office
hours i mean any of you guys certainly
an american it's amazing to me
faculty
give of their time and say here are my
office hours you're welcome to come and
nobody goes i mean i do this i mean some
do go but the fraction of students in a
class that actually show up for office
hours is tiny and certainly when i was a
student in the 1980s i was often the
only student so i'd have these long
multi-hour conversations over the course
of a semester with my professors and
robert nozick was one of them and i've
learned
so much about the philosophical way of
thinking his particular
views on reality and it's had a deep
impact on me i mean almost every book
that i've written i don't plan to
but robert knows it makes an appearance
because
it has such an impact on my way of
thinking about the world and i don't
even know if he remembered that i was
his student but one of the more
gratifying moments for me was when i
wrote my first book the elegant universe
i get this email from robert knows like
i was like wow robert knows it writing
to me and and he was praising the
elegant universe that she had just read
and um you know i i i i reminded him
that i had been you know one of the
students that
he'd spoken with over a long period of
time he didn't write back after that i
think he got sick very soon thereafter
and he died quite young but uh that that
would be the other philosopher that i
would give to answer your question
all right anyway guys it's uh 2 30 an
hour and a half i think i've i've
reached my limit on this first day back
in these live sessions let me just again
remind you
next thursday we will be releasing world
science festival our first of our
digital big ideas programs that will be
on the nature of mathematics is it
really discovered roughly every other
week or so we will be releasing new
content of that sort and i will try to
have these kinds of conversations
perhaps in the off week sometimes just
me sometimes we'll bring in folks again
anybody who you'd like us to bring in
natural ones that come to mind just
because they've been in the news avi
loeb again on extraterrestrials
uh perhaps a shep doleman on the event
horizon telescope
people of that sort but we'd love to
hear your suggestions
and again tell your friends
sign up world science festival
newsletter it's free and you'll just be
alerted when our content starts to roll
out and it's got gonna start to roll out
big time
starting
next week okay guys girls women men
everybody thanks for joining us here
today and we will look forward to uh
having these conversations going forward
and for the world science festival
release of our first
of our big ideas programs next week math
and reality until we meet again thanks
for joining us